okay well you have okay here's a you
know what sue can't believe you you just
bought something up related to this oh
you know we have a call yeah we're gonna
go to the car okay oh I'm sorry we we
have Natalie who I like to call Bev
sometimes just because I'm like that
that was lame those are lame come back
I'm watching you're here so Natalie is
on the line and she has a question you
go Natalie hello dr. Tyson I actually
had a question about some recent
advances in what seems to be a virus
let's say technology in that it seems a
lot of the players we encounter now
actually originated in other species and
so I was wondering is this level of
species crossing common to viruses or is
there anything that we're doing as
humans to encourage the formation of
these multi species viruses awesome
question and thanks Natalie so obviously
that's gonna have to go to Laurie
Garrett our like infectious disease
expert at the table Laurie what do you
have to say about that well a very smart
question and both of her posit answers
are correct so we have this process we
called zoonosis and that's the
transmission of viruses or bacteria for
that matter that are typically in one
set of species of animals and then boom
they jump to another so zoonosis has two
O's four for service ooh right and
zodiac comes from that as well not 12
animals yeah well at any rate the
zoonosis actually is a very dangerous
process because typically when a microbe
jumps for the first time to a species
that has not seen it before that species
has no immunity immunity to it and the
virus is very virulent typically in that
first leap and so for example I was in
the Ebola epidemic
1995 you scare the hell out of me yes
and that was a virus that had just
jumped from bats through chimpanzees to
humans and so it came in in its initial
wave it was more than 90% lethal and
after passed through humans for a while
it dumbed down that people it became
less and less now is that coming down a
result of our defenses or the virus
itself in its replication the virus if
you but why would a virus ever dumb down
yeah it is it well I don't want to say
this in a way that sounds like kind of
anthropomorphizing and putting a brain
into a virus the whole universe but the
virus is it's in the virus's interest to
remain in your species and so that you
walk around and spread it whereas if it
gets you so sick that you're immediately
flattened out and therefore not
particularly likely to infect others go
back to your zombie model you want the
zombies walking around trying to touch
on missions and turning them into
zombies right right I don't want a
zombie to immediately drop on the floor
and not move okay so it can't be
perfectly lethal it has to only be
mildly lethal so you have a chance to
spread it so why doesn't it maximize
that sort of let me not kill you
immediately factor for like I would say
maybe 60 years
so that would be HIV ah is a brilliantly
adapted virus to the homo sapiens
because it doesn't kill you immediately
it takes ten years or more if you're
untreated and during that time for most
of that time you're contagious to your
sexual partners to your who don't know
or don't know
and much of that time you have no
symptoms so you're unaware that you have
a dangerous disease you have the perfect
viral carrier it's a perfect viral
situation but but if you go back to
Natalie's question there are there two
key points here what is we are stressing
our planet in so many ways that millions
of species of creature
that carry viruses and bacteria inside
of them are being forced close to human
health this question they're displaced
their displays bats are the top of the
list and bats turn out to be the natural
carriers of the MERS virus the SARS
virus Ebola Marburg listen if we can go
down a huge list
why don't they won't die from these
diseases because well maybe they do and
we'll notice that oh they're immune
hoping not to die they seem to be
carriers they may get sick but they
don't get leaf ELISA and they pass it in
when they chew on fruit and they spit
out the pit since the one the viruses
are earth encased in that spit all if
you will and then our domestic animals
pigs or horses or what have you say well
there's some nice cheese food right and
they goes chomping up and they were you
just imitating the sound yeah just by
the way it was pretty good it was
actually good I was sloppy but sloppy
Pig never go on so she's right that
human activities are putting us at
greater risk the other is of course we
have a huge trade in exotic animals
there's all kinds of people who were all
sorts of I think dumb reasons like to
collect exotic species and there's it's
usually illegal to both collect and
smuggle okay so all of it is sub run and
therefore not easily you know controlled
by health officials and this is the way
that for example we had prairie dogs
dying across the Midwest at one point
from a virus that had never before been
seen in North America and it was all
because of smuggled animals it was
because they were so adorable they were
dying of cuteness I don't know if
anybody in Texas to tell you their
Perdido Key that's true so Nadia I think
we hit that one Natalie Natalie what I
call 19 Natalie so that way I think we
got that who do we get that one for you
I think so thank you very much yes the
answer is it's our fault there you go